voilà un siècle qu'ils dictent notre
conduite sentant qu'il fait la loi dans
nos rues c'est le code de la route des
règles et des règles par milliers zéro
de conduite ne pas se mettre encore
nourrir d'autres conducteurs stationnés
sur la route sans feux de position au 02
10 alors on a fait de perdre les pédales
de tous et zéro de conduite là dans les
années 60 l'auto se démocratise les
quatre roues brouille le respect du code
de la route devient une priorité mais ça
ne paraît pas évident pour tout le monde
même pour les règles de base monsieur à
une intersection
muni d'un panneau stop ou doit-on
marquer un temps d'arrêt je porte c'est
environ 100 mètres avant c'est à la
limite de l'intersection
[Musique]
et quand l'europe met son grain de sel
en 1973 de nouvelles règles surgissent
donc de nouveaux panneaux sur le bas
côté et pour les automobilistes
c'est la déroute je sais pas c'est pas
le truc de limitation de vitesse
en face et l'examen du code lui conduire
avaler les kilomètres
année après année à en oublier les
rudiments pour ces jeunes gens le code
de la route
c'était il ya cinquante ans alors
certains panneaux délaisse un peu
circonspect ont ralenti peut-être qu'il
faut pas ralentir
alors oui parfois un retour sur les
bancs de l'auto-école s'impose la
vitesse limitée à 70 chez hp logique
mais je ne sais pas chez moi je me
souviens pas votre j'ai passé mon permis
chacun sait que le code de la route est
loin d'être une bible figé et c'est
pareil pour son examen en 2016 et la
catastrophe quand il est réformé il
passe d'un panel de 700 à 1000 questions
et du jour au lendemain
le taux de réussite chute de 70 à 16
pour quand par exemple le talent heures
j'avais une question sur comment attaché
un bébé ou plein de petites plein de
petites subtilités comme ça qu'ils ont
moins à voir avec le jeu trouve le code
de la route on va dire il finalement
l'examen a rapidement été simplifié
connaître toutes les règles
ça reste un point d'étape primordiale
avant de conduire quitte à tout oublier
une fois le permis en poche
79 % des conducteurs français admettent
des écarts au code de la route
[Musique]